welcome back to Facebook the UN says
will be 11 billion humans by the year 2
100. sparking warnings of overpopulation
with famine disease conflict and even
complete societal collapse on the polar
opposite side of that debate though are
the pronatalists Elite Silicon Valley
couples who say birth rates are going to
fall and we should all breed more to
save Humanity Elon Musk is their most
famous African he's one of the smartest
guys in the world the world's richest
man and one of the cleverest as 10 of
his own kids and claims population
collapse due to low birth rates is a
much bigger risk to civilization than
global warming meanwhile down the road
in Montecito that world-renowned expert
on everything Prince Harry told Vogue in
2019 that he capped a number of kids
he's planning with Megan to help save
the world to to maximum he said he said
I've always thought this place is
borrowed and surely being as intelligent
as we all are at which point I'm afraid
he lost me
um so
move on from Harry's place because once
he says that he loses the argument one
couple at the center of the pronatalist
movement and the backlash to it are
Simone and Malcolm Collins from
Pennsylvania currently have three
children plan to expand their family to
seven and they join me now from
Philadelphia well welcome to both of you
so uh Simone let me start with you if I
may
um because you're doing the physical
side of this intensive reading um but
it's very interesting because I've
listened to Elon Musk about this and he
is absolutely adamant this is the
biggest threat actually along with
artificial intelligence to mankind is
the reverse of what most people think
it's actually a case of the population
levels tumbling to a level which is
going to endanger the planet explain to
people who think that's ridiculous why
that is a real situation
yes as as soon as societies basically
reach a level of modernity where there
is prosperity gender equality high level
high levels of Education
populations start to drop below
replacement rate that's a pretty serious
problem if it seems like modernity and
all the things that we consider to be
good like women's rights like Prosperity
like good quality of life seem
incompatible with flourishing humans it
seems wild to me that we live in a world
today we're not a single country or
culture except for maybe Israel has
found out how to maintain a stable
population alongside Prosperity gender
equality and education this as like a
civilization is probably something we
should start talking about
once I heard I was having you guys on
his guests I didn't read a lot about
this and it seems to be that the graph
the graph continues to rise population
until around the middle of a century but
then it could it could start to fall
precipitously after that
yes if you look at fertility rates today
the only countries that really have
above repopulation fertility rates are
where the average salary is under 4 000
pounds a year or five thousand USD a
year so you're really only seeing high
fertility rates in desperately poor
countries right now if you look at the
developed world the average fertility
rate is only around 1.5 and we need 2.1
just to keep stable populations okay and
someone you I know that you're planning
to have seven children of it you've got
three on on your belt literally
um how fast do you want to have the
seven what's the is the clock ticking
here
absolutely yeah we need to have them
basically as quickly spaced as possible
so we're going in for our next uh our
next round essentially next month and
we're going to have more than seven if
we can basically until my uterus is
forcibly removed in a botched surgery
I'm gonna keep going
I mean it is that we laugh about it but
there's a very serious point and it's
fascinating because the more I've dug
into it after actually Elon Musk said
what he said The more interesting it
becomes and look it is an argument which
is argued vehemently both ways you know
there are a lot of people who believe
the complete opposite but there are a
lot of smart people who think this is a
real doomsday thing coming around the
corner
yeah I mean I think we need to look at
how quickly fertility rates can collapse
when I started caring about this I was
working as a venture capital in Korean I
had to constantly plan out the future of
their economy at South Korea's current
fertility rate for every 100 South
Koreans there will be six
great-grandchildren we're looking at a
94 population collapse coming back to
places like the US and the UK it felt
like traveling two decades back in time
like I was in some sort of uh sci-fi
world and I got a chance to try to raise
the flag before it was too late because
when you hit a place like Korea where
Now 60 of the population is above the
age of 40 it's probably too late for
them to turn the situation around and
then there's all these economic problems
you can say what we can solve this with
immigration but then what you're doing
is you're making the developed World
Reliant their economies reliant on
keeping Africa poor or the African
countries poor that have these high
fertility rates and that's not a good
place to put the world in and then you
talk to the us about this and they go we
can solve this with immigration but as
of 2019 by the un's own statistics
collectively South America Central
America and the Caribbean fell by
Liberty population rate so I think
people are just they're not aware of how
far this problem has progressed
new countries in the world today yeah
and the numbers are pretty startling
actually uh I mean Simone the answer
clearly is we have to go back to massive
gender inequality right
no I mean the whole reason why we're
advocates in this entire space is we
really want a future in which there is
gender equality and if we don't take
measures now the future is one with
massive gender inequality right
basically the future of feminism
requires on more feminist people having
kids and raising them in a durable
culture that is feminist and this is
what was so funny
I'm sorry I'll run out of time I'm
actually going to get you guys back
another time because this is a really
interesting debate honestly I'm I'm I
find this really intriguing and your
great guest so thank you very much for
joining me now and we're going to do a
bigger debate on Miss down the line
after after our coronation's out the way
but but thank you Simona Malcolm I
appreciate you joining me thank you very
much
thank you we're excited too
we need the Royals to keep breeding and
we don't have a monarchy it's a very
least they're going to keep going